[Music]
Israeli forces surrounding Gaza City
this Thursday
night we will proceed and win as
civilians in Gaza have nowhere to run
and have dwindling
supplies what some people have resorted
to and why Israel doesn't want fuel led
into Gaza on the stand the former RCMP
intelligence director accused of sharing
Secrets testifies in his own defense
more than a million people powerless the
record-breaking storm pummeling Western
Europe and sketches in a secret room
it's hard to tell who is right and who
is wrong to debate over whether these
drawings are the work of Michael
Angelo global national with Donna
freezen this is the view from Southern
Israel of the Gaza Strip tonight
Israel's prime minister claims troops
are at the height of battle and have
moved into the heart of Gaza encircling
its largest city good evening and thanks
for joining us Israeli forces are
advancing and their ground assault is
getting more deadly the IDF released
this video tonight a military spokesman
saying its soldiers are now engaged in
face-to-face fighting Israel insists it
is attacking Hamas Outpost headquarters
and launch positions but another refugee
camp was hit today two in an area Israel
had said was safe gazan authorities say
at least 15 people were killed others
are buried under the rubble the health
Ministry run by Hamas says more than
9,000 people have been killed since
October 7th there's no way to
independently verify that Israeli
soldiers are dying too this is the
funeral for one of them at least 18 have
now died in the fighting in Gaza
Israel's prime minister rallied the
troops today telling them they are doing
sacred Duty
every fallen soldier is a loss he tells
them but nothing will stop us the
American Secretary of State is heading
back to the region tonight he's expected
to push for humanitarian pauses we'll
have more on that in a moment but we
begin with Mike Armstrong in a warning
some of what you're about to see is
disturbing in the first days of this
conflict Suzanne beso says she made a
mistake the Palestinian American could
have left Gaza but waited as it turns
out too long finally able to board a bus
for Egypt Thursday on her fifth try she
says she was torn to be leaving I don't
know if I'm ever going to be able to see
the family that I left before behind or
the friends that I left
behind people are dying everybody's
dying nobody's
safe now there was some movement into
Gaza Aid trucks were allowed to cross
from Egypt according to the World Health
Organization since October 7th 2117
trucks have made it in the need on the
ground it says would take 300 per day at
the very least we need a humanitarian
pose in the
fighting those calls for a ceasefire
aren't being answered Israeli troops say
they pushed deeper into Gaza Thursday
surrounding Gaza
City the Israel Defense Forces say
they're taking out hamas's front defense
lines and controlling more and more
territory that does leave civilians in
the crossfire the Hamas Le Gaza health
authority says since October 7th more
than 9,000 people have been killed in
the strip including 3,400 children un
officials say the fighting and
bombardments have also left more than
1.4 million people homeless and
struggling for every basic
need you wait in line for bread this man
says you wait in line for water you wait
in line to charge a phone now access to
clean water is a growing problem Gaza
operates six large treatment plants and
two desalination facilities with fuel
supplies choked off by Israel none of
those are working some un officials have
gone as far as accusing Israel of using
water as a weapon of
War this woman says she's been drinking
salt water that things are so desperate
she's doing things she knows are
wrong this girl says she has headaches
and stomach pains her family is sick
from drinking polluted
water Israel's prime minister says the
cabinet is considering supplying fuel to
Gaza they're allowing in some food and
water but fuel is a different matter the
issue of diesel is is crucial this
former Israeli National Security adviser
says Israel will be stubborn on fuel it
may be a humanitarian need he says but
it's also something Hamas needs to keep
hiding underground and continue fighting
they need the diesel for the electricity
otherwise they need to get out of their
tunnels because without Air Supply they
cannot live in those tunnels and this is
dramatic now Hamas may need fuel for air
Communications even light in those
tunnels but its needs may not be that
urgent Israeli intelligence believes the
group has stockpiles that could last 3
or 4 months Donna all right Mike
Armstrong in Jerusalem thanks about 800
foreign Nationals and severely injured
Palestinians have now been able to leave
Gaza at the Rafa Crossing no Canadians
are believed to be among them we're
pushing on our friends in Israel on our
friends in uh in Egypt uh uh working
with Americans and others uh to make
sure that the Canadian families get on
the list uh we're we're not going to
stop until we get them out Canada's
prime minister is among those who have
called for humanitarian pauses in the
fighting and it now looks like the US
Israel's most important Ally is going to
do the same for the first time President
Joe Biden voiced support for the idea on
Wednesday his secretary of state will be
in Israel tomorrow our Washington bureau
chief Jackson prco is with me Jackson
what are we expecting his message to
Israel will
be hi Donna in the view of the US a
pause would allow hostages and foreign
Nationals out of Gaza and humanitarian
Aid in the White House says it's pushing
the Israeli government for as many
pauses as necessary to accomplish those
goals US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin is tonight on route to Israel
where he's expected to press prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu directly
notable here is the language the US is
increasingly Direct in demanding that
civilians be protected the Americans
believe they can extract concessions
from Netanyahu because of the solidarity
they've shown with Israel so far we've
seen in recent days Palestinian
civilians continue to Bear the brunt
of this uh this action uh and it's
important and the United States has
committed to making sure everything
possible is done to protect civilians
the US says it also wants discussions to
focus on what happens after the current
conflict the Americans view a two-state
solution as the only way forward in the
long term the timing is delicate the
leader of Hezbollah hamas's Ally in
Lebanon is expected to address the
conflict for the first time during a
speech on Friday
no doubt it will be watched closely by
the Americans for hints about whether a
wider Regional war is in the making
Donna all right jackon prco in
Washington thanks Sam bankman freed
whose FTX cryptocurrency exchange
collapsed last year has been found
guilty of all seven charges he faced
including fraud conspiracy and money
laundering he was accused of stealing as
much as 10 billion dollars from
customers to finance political
contributions Venture Capital
Investments and other extravagant
spending the jury of nine women in Tre
men in New York deliberated for a few
hours before their verdict it makes
bankman freed one of the largest
financial frauders in history he FES a
maximum sentence of 115 years and is
widely expected to appeal there was some
extraordinary testimony at a trial in
Ottawa today Cameron ordis a former
high-ranking RCMP intelligence official
took the stand he's accused of leaking
classified information to targets of
criminal investigations and his lawyers
says he was protecting Canada when he
did it as David Aken explains the
testimony is being carefully handled
David well Donna what's not in dispute
here is this fact while he was director
of RCMP intelligence Cameron ordis
shared top secret information with
criminals the prosecution said what Oris
did was illegal though it has not yet
presented evidence as to motive why did
ordis do what he did well on Thursday
ordis himself took the stand in a
courtroom cleared of reporters and
others in order to protect National
Security where according to his lawyer
ortis was going to testify that his
actions were in large part as a result
of secret information communicated to
him by a foreign agency but again for
national security reasons the jury
cannot be told any details of that
secret information nor can it know the
identity of that foreign agency from the
witness box ortis was also expected to
explain that he had the lawful authority
to do what he did and how in doing so he
was fulfilling his mission of Defending
Canada now ortis is going to be on the
stand for 3 days all of it behind closed
doors in case by accident a top secret
bit of information is revealed but the
court has said it will release
transcripts of that testimony cleaned of
any secrets and those transcripts will
provide more information about oris's
means motive and his mission Donna okay
David aen thanks Canada's public inquiry
into allegations of foreign interference
is underway and the judge who is heading
it laid out the framework today the
first phase will focus on accusations of
interference by China Russia and other
foreign actors and any impact that might
have had on the 2019 and 2021 Federal
elections the second phase will look
into how the federal government can
detect and counter interference public
hearings are expected to start in early
2024 the commissioner says she aims to
maximize transparency without putting
National Security at risk the first
report is due at the end of February
Canada's Ministry of defense is
confirming tonight its military aircraft
did not enter China's airspace on
October 16th Global News was on board a
Canadian Armed Forces plane that day
when it was intercepted by a Chinese jet
using what Canadian Forces call risky
Maneuvers the plane was taking part in a
mission to support sanctions against
North Korea NE Gara
explains St St station these Canadian
Pilots put to the test holding the plane
steady off the coast of China they're
not making any sudden
moves they have the right to intercept
us but they need to do so professionally
and safely equipped with air-to-air
missiles a Chinese jet Banks back and
forth firing flares from in front and
flying within close proximity I deal
with the radar with the camera as
Corporal casha Fraser is busy on the
nearly 9-hour Mission above the East
China and yellow Seas on October 16th
others document on cameras an intercept
that would be reported up the chain to
Ottawa as soon as the plane lands back
on base Canada's minister of National
Defense called the Chinese Jet's actions
Reckless the next day the Chinese
foreign Ministry blamed Canada for the
incident saying the Aurora in intruded
in China's airspace flying over a set of
disputed Islands both China and Japan
claim as theirs but the Canadian
Ministry of Defense confirmed Thursday
the unsafe intercept did not take place
near those islands and Canada's military
remained in international airspace in an
effort to try to get uh North Korea to
abandon its weapons of mass destruction
program uh and its uh ballistic missile
test program a mission assisted by
Canadian Navy members on board hmcs
Vancouver we got a behind the scenes
look at the ship and how they support
operation neon we're operating above
board again in support of the
rules-based international order that we
would be let's say in in international
airspace and we're not inside someone's
territorial Waters the crew on hmcs
Vancouver did not report any dangerous
intercepts on the water the question now
is whether China is trying to challenge
International airspace similar to the
way it's challenged Allied ships in the
Taiwan straight
Ottawa highlights its concerns about the
dangerous intercepts are being raised
through diplomatic channels Nara Global
News there are more alarming signs
hatred against Muslims in Canada is on
the rise today the Senate's human rights
committee released its report looking
into islamophobia it was conducted over
the past year and it found that one in
four Canadians say they don't trust
Muslims the evidence is clear
islamophobia is an acute threat to
Canadian Muslims an urgent action is
needed we must commit to building a more
inclusive country and to better
promoting our Muslim relatives and
Friends neighbors and
colleagues the report found Canada leads
G7 countries in targeted killings
motivated by islamophobia it also found
Muslim women were primary targets of
violence intimidation and
microaggressions in part because of
their recognizable attire why the
Alberta Government wants to ditch the
Canada Pension Plan and create its own
fund coming up why some retirees are
worried the Alberta Government has taken
another step towards creating its own
Pension Plan Premier Danielle Smith's
government tabled new legislation today
it says we'll give Alberton some peace
of mind about its plans though it's not
clear if albertans want to withdraw from
the Canada Pension Plan and that will
play a role in how the province moves
forward Heather urick West
explains
enjoying their retirement these Calgary
seniors are creating art and sharing
their thoughts on whether Alberta should
exit Canada's pension plan I think it's
ridiculous why well the CPP has worked
for us for a long time it works very
well so I don't see why you would want
to change something that is working well
the government of Alberta disagrees the
new plan could mean higher benefits for
seniors and bigger paychecks for workers
in ads and telephone Halls it's been
selling an independent a though the
provincial Finance Minister says
ultimately albertans will have the final
say that's why I'm pleased to table the
Alberta pension protection act today to
provide reassurance to albertans that
this is their pension and their choice
under this new legislation The Province
cannot set up a new pension plan or
withdraw from the CPP until after a
non-binding referendum is held but there
are questions around exactly what
Alberton would be voting on the Alberta
Government commissioned an independent
report that says the province is
entitled to withdraw 52% of the CPP but
critics question that number saying it's
based on the CPP allocation formula from
when the fund was established in the
1960s the challenge here is that the
language of the Canada Pension Plan act
itself is imprecise and vague and so
opens the door to a lot of potential
interpretations the CPP is delivering
it's why the Federal Finance Minister
has called an emergency meeting of her
provincial counterparts to discuss the
issue Friday back in this art class The
Proposal remains a tough cell there's no
concrete figures the fact that they
think that we can take out 334 billion
out of the plan is ridiculous I'm
definitely voting no
emphatically and Alberta decision that
could impact the retirements of
Canadians Countrywide Heather urex West
Global News Calgary
Canada's Western Hockey League is making
neck guards mandatory for all players
starting tomorrow or as soon as teams
can get the equipment the changes come
after former NHL player Adam Johnson was
cut on his neck by a skate during a game
in England and died the WHL is one of
three major junior hockey leagues in
Canada the others already require
players to wear neck guards the NHL has
not said if it will follow
suit deadly disaster ahead storm kieron
reeks havoc on parts of
[Music]
Europe
Jesus a man on England's Cornish Coast
had a close call as a record-breaking
storm slammed into parts of the UK storm
Kiron packed hurricane force winds gusts
of up to 160 kmph there is localized
flooding uprooted trees and power
outages at least six people have been
killed in the storm and as Crystal
ganing Reports the damage extends to
Western
Europe gusting winds rainfalling
sideways treacherous conditions for
emergency crews working to clear an area
where a woman was killed by a falling
tree several others were injured in the
Spanish Capital as a result of storm
Kieran in France the interior Minister
visited a storm crisis center extreme
wind led to a truck driver being killed
Northwest of Paris and 1.2 million
French households had their power
knocked
out the storm period is not over yet
said the minister we have to continue
being attentive to the security measures
hurricane strength winds whipped up
destruction throughout parts of
Northwestern
Europe across the English Channel and
through parts of the UK a power jet
stream that swept in from the Atlantic
propelled Kieran the second Nam storm to
make landfall in the UK in 2 weeks the
satellite image from the UK's National
Weather Service of the conditions
Wednesday night shows the heavy rain
lightning and thunder that blanketed the
region Jersey is the largest of the
Channel Islands between England and
France and was one of the community's
hardest hit dozens of families are now
being housed in hotel HS after their
homes were damaged schools and doctor's
offices will remain closed Friday as the
community enters what's being called a
recovery
stage rainfall warnings are expected to
remain in place for Northeastern England
and Eastern Scotland until Friday
Crystal Ganson Global News
London next was this secret room
decorated by Michelangelo during the
Renaissance
a once secret room has been open to the
public in Florence Italy and in it are
drawings on the walls that have not been
seen for centuries it's thought they
might be the work of the Renaissance
artist Michael Angelo but the jury is
still out Redmond Shannon explains what
they are and why they're so
special he looks pretty good for a guy
more than 500 years old but even David
needs a little beauty treatment now and
then Michelangelo's marble Masterpiece
is a mustsee for art lovers who visit
Florence a short stroll away are the
Chapels of one of Michelangelo's patrons
the powerful medich family inside is a
secret room used as a coal bunker until
the 1950s it was then sealed up and
rediscovered in
1975 when Museum workers removed layers
of plaster these magnificent sketch were
revealed some people think that this is
the rule where Michelangelo sheltered in
1530 when he was um under uh death
threat because of Clement II Pope
Clement iith was a mediche and was
enraged by Michelangelo for supporting a
political push against the family
proving this was his Hideout is next to
Impossible this sketch appears to be of
a Michelangelo sculpture elsewhere in
the chapel that of Clement's cousin
Giuliano deichi other think that these
drawings were probably made in the 16th
century but not by niichel Angelo's hand
but by some of other followers so it's
hard to tell who is right and who is
wrong starting this month visitors can
decide for themselves the argument will
be reinvigorated as we open the room to
the public and I hope the scholars will
come back pae and look at the drawing
and start to do more analysis in due
Force this is literally not for everyone
for now just 100 people a week will be
granted tickets each group of four
limited to 15 precious minutes inside
Redmond Channon Global News London